this is it looks intimidating okay but
no the most intuitive part of this is
something they're giving us for free
right it's like don't approve this
you're going to use this in a second it
looks terrible but that's why I'm trying
to save you the work ok so then give you
this identity and then they say okay
here's what I want you to prove okay so
just put the identity to one side for a
second I don't understand it yet let's
look at where we're headed for NC to em
what's that that was the answer to
partner on wasn't it right good morning
in other words it's the coefficient of x
to the 2n in this thing okay but one of
the first things you told me before I
even started doing this question is that
since this and this these two are the
same right so that's the coefficient of
x 22 m in part 1i have guessing this is
how you get the coefficient of x 0 to n
in part two because they're the same
thing just viewed from two different
angles does that make sense okay so far
so good so I have to tease out the
coefficient of x to the 2n in here and
it looks a bit disastrous is it not okay
and that's why they give you part 3 so
pause for a moment before we look at
pi/3 look at part two and see what it's
actually telling you okay Sigma notation
it's all about saving time it's all
about saving time this is saying look
there's a whole bunch of things you need
to add up there's a whole bunch of
things you need to add up and then when
you consider like let's just don't write
this down but just consider it with me
let's think about one of those things
you need to add up just one of them okay
so for instance let's pick a value like
say k equals 1 i'm choosing because cake
was 0 is too simple form of see why in a
second the k equals 1 term looks like
this to NC 1 X to the 2n minus 1 X plus
2 to the power to em max 1 does that
make sense have I done this opposition
right
now this is just one of the two n plus 1
terms that's going to come out of this
right so this is telling me how you're
going to have a whole bunch of these to
add up but look at this guy look at this
guy this thing itself is also once you
expand this is this a big long term
right let's you expand that whole thing
out it's going to have a buttload of
terms in it right so you're adding up
you've got a series of a bunch of
syriza's okay so this is it that's
that's why seeing notation is used
because it's just too much to actually
try and write the whole thing up okay so
have a look at this for me just this one
okay do you see in here one of these
terms in the big expansion is going to
have the power X to the 2n do you notice
that and one of the must write out of a
big long list of them one of them
eventually will this guy will combine
with the powers of this using your index
laws and eventually one of them will
have a power of X 0 to it yes so I need
to find which one it is okay I need to
look if every single one of these and
find the X to the 2n and the next exit
around and the next extra to it right so
hopefully they say well you know what
this thing I don't expect you to expand
it that's why I've expanded it for you
do you see why they've given you this
identity okay because that's a that's a
disaster right so do you see the
trajectory on try to go through now
because we're about to start doing this
question we identified this we said oh
that's the edge of the part 1 it's a
particular coefficient in this thing but
these things are the same so if it's a
particular coefficient here I need to
find where all those coefficients come
in here and that should be this thing is
crossed okay alright so now that you've
got an idea of where we're going to go
let's try to solve this thing let's try
to show
okay so yes it but then I can't just say
that this term there's no a song save it
again like for the hot yeah it only
shows this part is equals to yes yes
that's okay that's all right let's still
do the working and you'll see I know
that was a that was a confusing part for
me too when I was trying to solve this
question when I get to that point in the
proof I'll try and address that okay
alright so the first thing you need to
do is a lot the stuff you said
informally I'd better put it down right
we can't just assume odd they'll get it
right so for part three the first thing
I say is no fat okay you've got
equivalence between the things the
results you look at in part 1 and part 2
ok so I'm going to say note that one
plus X to the 4 n is equal to 1 plus x
squared to the power 2 n i'm just using
index laws there and that is 1 plus x
squared I'm just writing it in the
unusual water they presented to me a
part 2 ok so I show that that's
equivalent you could have done it in
reverse if you liked so therefore since
part 1 from part 1 the coefficient of x
to the 2n in 1 plus X to the floor n is
this ok
therefore it's also the coefficient of
the same power of X in this other way of
my team this same binomial expansion
okay just it looks a little bit Messier
but it's going to be helpful for us in a
second okay so we've got those too I've
invoked part 1 and part 2 as well so the
hell what's left is to use what's in
part 3 okay so i'm going to write down
the results so that i could actually use
it from part 3 from the identity
provided this thing here just this part
and this is important to note maybe if
you have another color for yourself you
want to underline it this part here they
tell us what the expansion is ok so I'm
going to say that actual expansion ok
now for reasons that will become clear
in a second when you have a look kicking
it will look at the actual identity they
give you in part 3 they give you
something a bit unusual I suppose
they're trying to save some space they
give you a zero turn to n minus K c0
they give you a one-term to n minus K
see one and then they skip a few and
they get you to the enth sorry the case
term okay I actually want to make an
argument about a series of things in a
second so I'm not going to just do the
first second and then skip to the
general one I'm going to do the first
second and third terms because then I
can have a patent established okay so
first I'm just going to write out what
they've given me but i'm going to add an
extra turn in there okay i think i'm
going to need a new more it's going to
look like this
to the X
that's k minus 1 right yep
okay here is where I'm going to pause
for a second so I started to write out
what they've given me right and now i am
trying to put down a term that they have
not provided for me so what i need to do
is understand what is going on in this
pattern in order to be able to
generalize it to the next one ok have a
look at what is happening as I
progressed yet have I missed something x
2 n minus k plus 1 i'm sorry ok of
course it is so whatever look at this
yeah 2mo escape action yeah yeah because
it's actually minus K minus y that's why
um when you have a look at this what is
happening as I increment up each time ok
so I've done the easy part I see this
has gone 0 1 2 that's ok what happens to
the power of 2 it drops down by one do
you see that sorry that you feel to it
went from trimmers k to turn moments k
minus 1 so the next one should be 2 n
minus K minus 2 so it's reduced
conversely what's happened to power of X
it has gone from 2 minus K 2 to n minus
k plus 1 so it's going up while this
one's going down that makes sense that's
what binomials do ok so i'm going to
write that out to n minus k plus 2 ok
now I've got three terms now I'm ready
to dot dot dot generalize so you can see
they've provided us the lusts order yeah
the last time in their series it's like
this
make sure I get it right this time
ok